okay members we've just gone
call to pass so i'll ask katie if she
can set the
youtube feed live for us so one second
for me and i'll let you know when we're
good to go
thank you james
okay we're live over to you chair thank
you thank you james
uh good afternoon members officers
and the general public and i welcome you
to this uh
planning meeting on the 21st of april
uh 2021 one thing i would like to say
before we
actually start the agenda um
is for members of the public as we all
know this is live streamed
we know every application that comes
before uh
for is important but today
um is a rather large
application um there's been a lot of
comments
and what i'd just like to say is people
who have written
to us as members myself as chair
um email or in writing
if you don't get an acknowledgement
please do not think that is
because it's ignored i am aware that
certain members do
reply uh with a thanks um but i also
will have to say that a member of this
committee
we are not by law allowed to comment
on a either pre-determination error or
thoughts
that is left for this meeting so i hope
the members the public understand that
it's not
you're ignored far far from it um
this committee takes things uh
everything that's in front of us very
seriously and uh
and i have said once again it has worked
well since all the lockdown systems have
been in place okay as usual members i
will read out
your names to make sure you are
with us um so you know the ropes fine
now if you could say
yes if i don't hear from you i will come
back just to see if you have arrived
um if not he'd be absent councillor
coleman cook
here too councilman robin yeah here
chair
councillor joe badford here
councillor curry your chair
a councillor dennis here chair
councillor pat moore
here chair uh councillor ghana
i'm here councillor hart
here chair councillor keane
councillor paul moore here chair
councillor scott
and i heard movement there come back
there councilorski
president councillor wright
wheelchair and obviously myself
um also on the line tonight we have
our planet applications manager mr
livingston
uh planning manager annabelle hebbins
um mr james
waite who is kent highway is kcc
highways
uh james capstone who is uh democratic
services
um montego montag
sorry if i got that wrong but that's our
legal officer
and katie who's in the background who
will take calls from members
if necessary
so welcome everybody if you
once again members of the public i'm
sure we have quite an audience there
this afternoon
um i will go through the process as
usual and
if you have any technical differences
during the meeting then please contact
democratic services
who are on call who will attempt to
assist you
today it is katie and her number is
507.046
and this will be placed as uh it will be
thank you katie it is in the chat box on
your right and uh thank you
uh councillor scott you are here now uh
i would ask participants to mute your
microphone when you are not speaking
this minimizes background noise and will
help
everyone in listening to the proceedings
microphones must only be on if the
participant has been granted
permission to speak to gain permission
to speak
would you please indicate once again
in the chat box it is a lot easier if
you don't my members than raising
the hand on the page and as i've said
before if i don't
catch your name coming up please please
indicate and
shout to me um would everybody present
please ensure that their mobile phones
are turned to silent
and they are not used to make or receive
phone calls once the meeting's in
progress
please also refrain from checking emails
or conducting
other business and ensure that you're in
a quiet room free from distractions
uh for any for the duration of the
meeting
you also note that this meeting is being
live streamed
members of the public and the following
the meeting the recording of this
meeting will be on the council's
youtube channel
members requesting to speak under
council procedure
20.1 i have councillor gregory
council of parents councillor boyd
and councillor pew are there any other
members
who are listening uh wish to speak under
20.1 who aren't on the committee
there isn't thank you very much item
number one
apologies for absence i have apologies
from
councillor keane are there any other
apologies
thank you item two declarations of
interest
are there any declarations of interest
no agenda item
three which is scheduled are planning
applications
and public speaking um i just will
hand over to um mr livingston
who has a point of information for
members
thank you chairman um just a few updates
with regards to the
item on the agenda this evening um
one issue relates to condition six on
the agenda which refers specifically to
a parameter plan for the proposed
development um officers need to update
the plan
reference to include revision c
at the end of the reference to uh csa
4430122
and that's the plan that we've consulted
upon and it's the plan that members will
be seeing
shown this evening in the heads of terms
in that section of the agenda reference
is made to the split of tenure
of the affordable housing now this is
being updated
by officers from what's in the agenda uh
to 80 affordable rent and 20
shared ownership or future affordable
housing product in the report it's down
as
70 30 split but that's not what's
reflected in
the um in the viability information
and the last thing from me before we get
going um there have been 11 objections
that have been received by the council
directly since publishing the agenda
and they've raised the same issues as
summarized in the agenda that's before
you
this evening thank you thank you very
much ian
okay moving on to agenda item 3a
which is the land on the north west and
south east sides of shotenbane road
margate
we'll ask the legal officer tsuki now to
read out the public statements
if you would sookie thank you cher yes
there are four statements and i'll start
with the statement of the applicant
this is the applicant supporting
statement of mr ball planning director
gladman developments limited
i would begin by expressing my thanks to
members for the opportunity to provide
this statement
i also extend my thanks to officers for
the time they have
dedicated to considering this
application the advice that has been
provided from pre-application stage
through to today has always been of the
highest professional standard
the application site is a strategic
housing allocation
under policy sp 21 of the fanet local
plan
as will be noted from our submission
although the allocation expected the
site
could accommodate 550 homes our
application proposes up to
450. the reduced quantity of housing
is a necessary response to enable us to
accommodate
site constraints alongside site
infrastructure
in preparing our proposals we have kept
site delivery at the forefront of our
thinking
master planning has occurred intuitively
as key evidence has become available
all notable findings have been relayed
to relevant offices from fannet council
and
kent county council at the earliest
opportunity
given the extent of evidence that has
informed our submission
we have the utmost confidence that the
plans before you are deliverable
and have agreed to conditions that
require future applications to accord
with these principles
it is of course important to acknowledge
that delivery leads not
only to new housing but also a new link
road
which is an important component of the
inner circuit road
improvement scheme that will bring wider
strategic benefits
plus creating a bypass around coffin
house corner
it is because of these benefits we have
spent additional time
satisfying ourselves that the alignment
and the geometry of the road
can be achieved and have carried out
significant
engagement with kent county highway
authority
as set out within the officer report we
have committed to entering into a legal
agreement
that safeguards the internal route
corridor of the link
road the agreement also safeguards
further land in the west of the site
that can be drawn on
by the county council if it is
successful
securing major road network funding
unfortunately the engineering challenge
of delivering the link road
comes with abnormal costs that have had
to be considered alongside
other contribution requests we have been
open about the effect of these costs on
our submitted
viability appraisal the appraisal has
been confirmed by the council's
independent expert
who agrees that the affordable houding
housing proposed results in a deficit in
the benchmark
land value to effectively balance
viability against the potential future
funding of the link road
by kent county council we have worked
with
officers to agree on an infrastructure
pot
that will allow kent to determine where
requested
contribution funds are best directed we
have also agreed to a review mechanism
that would enable county contributions
to be topped up
in the event it is successful in
securing mrn
funding that's major road network
funding
there will also be a separate review
that will capture
changes in development viability with
any identified surplus
then channeled towards off-site
affordable housing
we have worked collaboratively with
officers to bring you this application
today
we fully endorse their recommendation
and hope you can
too just excuse me a moment chairman
right um this is the um second statement
and it is a statement objecting to the
application from mr
dickman vice chair samson ward
residents association and he says
i am seeking to oppose planning
application olth200847 on the following
grounds
highways and ecology highways
manson shottenden are main arteries into
margate especially for tourists
developments at sandstone and manston
shottenden would increase
traffic flow exponentially
manson road is unique as it has a school
crematorium
graveyard and the public refuge center
all within 800 metres of each other
thus being a highway for a high level of
local traffic
this combined with holiday traffic often
results in manston road
becoming gridlocked at various times
throughout the year
i feel that the proposed changes in
traffic routes
and the increase in traffic will
inevitably have a negative effect
on local residents the community wishing
to use the vital amenities and tourism
on thanet
ecology along with the proposed
development in the field adjacent to
selmson grange
there will be a total of 700 houses
stretching down from the high ground at
samson
into the valley of the field at the
northwest of shuttington road
i have a major concern that the extra
water
from 700 roofs drain pipes and hard
surfaces
will inevitably find its way to the
lowest point in the valley
as the tivoli brook runs through the
valley and is joined by a confluence of
other brooks
i believe that there is a very real risk
of flooding
which is borne out by previous history
perhaps my greatest concern is that the
brook
eventually empties into the margate main
sands
and a large influx of water from
residential dwellings
combined with nitrates from the existing
fields
could well have a detrimental effect on
the coastal water quality
in my view this development potentially
contravenes the recommendations in the
national planning policy framework
section 14 subsection 166
brackets meeting the challenge of
climate change flooding
and coastal change close brackets and
section 15
subsection 170 brackets conserving and
enhancing
the natural environment close brackets
can we please ensure that
a verification report has been carried
out on the effect of surface water
by an independent and qualified
professional
as my greatest fear is that this
development could have a catastrophic
effect
on than its tourist industry which our
growth is dependent on
rowan dickman okay there is now a
statement objecting to the application
from mrs channing
i am writing to object to the above
planning application on two
separate grounds common sense and social
responsibility
stroke conscience firstly in terms of
common sense and practicality
a development of this size and in this
position makes
very little sense the loss of prime
agricultural land
made even more important by our choice
to leave the eu
and seek home-grown produce as well as
land which supports a range of flowers
and animals must surely be protected
in addition there have been no less than
three new developments
started or completed in less than a mile
of shutting down road in the past five
years
and of those not yet completed at the
top and bottom of nash road
it is my understanding that these have
not all been sold off plan
how can the developer and the council
justify the need
for additional housing when we are
already offering these resources
elsewhere
secondly and just as significantly i
object to the development on the grounds
of social and moral conscience
having worked in teaching in the local
areas for the majority of my life
i can see firsthand the levels of
poverty and deprivation that
students and their families encounter in
the local area
one of the most deprived wards in kent i
can see that the developer has made a
cursory mention of
access points public outdoor space and a
play area
where is there or indeed the council's
if this is approved
commitment to supporting local
infrastructure transportation services
education
approximately 1800 new residents in
planet
as we know that in the current climate
and due to the levels of deprivation
mentioned in the local area above that
the people of thanet will not
be able to take advantage of this new
development or they would have already
done so
in the other developments already on
offer we'll be using these already
stretched and struggling services
finally it is the responsibility of the
council to ensure that the needs of the
existing community of phanet is best
served
i am yet to find any compelling evidence
that developments of this sort and in
this sort of position
benefit anyone in the local community
rather this development would destroy a
piece of much
needed green space in an area already
over served with housing developments of
this sort
as well as disadvantaging the people of
thailand still further
by increasing competition for employment
of which we already have the dubious
honor
of having most adults unemployed in the
county of kent
saturating the local schools and
amenities and placing further strain or
health and social care
in the community i can see all these
issues arising from approval for this
development
and not one concrete advantage to the
community living there
i would urge the council to reject this
proposal
based on the above grounds and to keep
the needy in our community
already in their minds and hearts and
finally there is a statement objecting
to the application from mr woodward
he says this development is in the local
character area the planet undulating
chalk farmland this is described in the
local plan as an
area of high quality agricultural land
or value for farmland
and roasting coastal birds the openness
and undeveloped character of the
farmland contributes to the essentially
rural character and relatively dark
skies
also a part of the national character
area
the north kent plains natural england
quotes fannet forms a discreet and a
distinct area
characterized by its unity of land use
arising from high quality fertile soils
open with few trees the area is
dominated by
wide views over an extensive land cover
of cereals
root crops and other horticultural crops
it states that we need to manage and
enhance the productive agricultural
landscape
including support for the area's
farmland birds and that it will be more
important to safeguard
high quality agricultural land in
development planning
it adds that future development should
seek to protect
and enhance the assets which provide a
strong sense of place
increasing sense of history could lead
to increased sense of place
by reinforcing the historic character of
the landscape
this landscape is vital for food
production and protected farmland birds
including those identified by defra
the lap wing red shank and corn bunting
and the infamous skylarks
it forms part of a functional land keep
the coastal birds of the protected sba
stroke sssi coast it is also the last
part of central planet with relatively
dark skies
supporting six species of protected bats
and species of protected
owls this area provides tranquility and
open space
vital for mental health footpath tm-14
on the boundary of the development is on
adjacent land
currently an open countryside enjoyed by
many
planets heritage is based on thousands
of years of farming
farming is the fabric of our landscape
if this plan gets approved
all of this will change by not engaging
with local farmers throughout the
planning process and by not considering
the current use of land and the economic
viability of the farmer who is producing
food on these two fields in question the
central character area is likely to lose
current farming practice
eroding the current benefits it provides
this development is viewed in isolation
but is connected to birchington and
westgate's
sixteen hundred and fifty and two
thousand houses
via the inner circuit road development
and section 106 payments
all these developments are in the same
character area and combined
will lead to a loss of thirty to forty
percent of the high quality farmland
which as stated should be safeguarded
the housing
street lit roads and roundabouts
associated with this development
will remove the last patch of dark skies
in the area
currently vital for protected species
including bats and little owls
as mentioned in agenda item 3a page
35-37
the remaining central farmland will be
carved up by road improvements footpath
and bridal way upgrades
all of this is on land owned by the same
farmer who farms the shuttington fields
none of this has been assessed we know
because the farmer has never been
consulted
if farms become unviable this landscape
and its functionality will change
it is that simple the following policies
are affected by this
proposal policy sp 14.5
general housing policy regarding
assessment and mitigation of functional
land for roosting and feeding birds
policy sp 28 regarding the protection of
the international and european
designated sites
policy sp 30 regarding restoration and
enhancement of existing habitats
and mitigation against the loss of
farmland bird habitats there is no
provision for this
policy sp 31 biodiversity opportunity
areas
owned by farmers whose viability is
affected investment on their part to
enhance biodiversity will come into
question
policy sc-08 light pollution
this will be impacted this will be
impact on the character of the
surroundings
and on protected and vulnerable species
due to increased
traffic and street lights in the last
dark part of planet
policy sp 34 the wider countryside will
be reduced
this will impact recreation and
enjoyment of the current population
policy sp 36 conservation and
enhancement of planet's historic
environment
farming farmland and its unique soils is
than its historic environment it is
being lost
policy sp 38 healthy and inclusive
communities
access to nature will not be improved
finally
policy sp 26 states that the council
will identify and support opportunities
to conserve
planet's landscape character and local
distinctiveness
including that of the central part of
the district with a sense of openness
and big skies
developments should demonstrate how they
will conserve and enhance
planets local distinctiveness should
this development go ahead
the damage will be irreparable thank you
chair
thank you very much sukhi um well done
thank you
uh normally members as you're fully
aware
when we're in normal times speakers
would only have three minutes now we
have or i have
sort of waved that rule over the past 12
months
i know we have um speakers under 20.1
coming up
um i will do similar but i will keep an
eye on the time
and try not to repeat
um what each other if i
if i make sense there so uh um i want to
be fair with everyone on
on timing uh so first of all if i may
call award counselor
uh councillor gregory
thank you chair i've got two points and
my first point is
senate district council declared a
climate emergency
in july 2019 and tdc
resolved to address the loss and
reduction
of agricultural land to address plant
and animal diseases
and tdc stated we are running out of
time before these changes become
irreversible we can still do something
about it but we have to start to act
now that's what makes it an emergency
these are tdc's words
right too the legal agreement submitted
in support of this
application contains this commitment
388 800 pounds towards creating capacity
at the lymes medical practice or within
the primary care network
this is the cost of one of the proposed
new houses but while that money
may provide bricks it won't provide the
staff
needed for the limestone function with
the expectations for this development
the clinical commissioning group the
lyme's catchment area in this proposal
alone
estimates 1080 new patient registrations
the ccgs state there must be appropriate
medical service capacity
and any planned developments need to
support delivery of sustainable services
for the future
currently the uk has 2.8 doctors per
thousand of population
and this is well below the uku
eu average and the situation is
worsening
the royal college of gps identify kent
as particularly
deprived of gps needing at least
a 50 increase in gp numbers
to cope with the population changes and
shortage of doctors
kent currently has around 850 gps
24.4 percent of them are over the age of
55 and some
will consider early retirement
since 2019 the royal college of gps cite
a 3.7 drop in their numbers of full-time
gps
since 2015 the last
national gp work-life survey reported
that two out of every five gps intend to
leave in the next five years
if this development goes ahead having an
additional
1080 patients will add an extra burden
of stress
on an already stressed workforce making
early retirement
even more attractive together with
the gp shortages is the government's
sustainability
and transformation plan which provo
proposes
a 10 reduction in hospital beds by 2021
for kent this is 300 fewer beds
you will already noticed many services
cut from qeqm with patients traveling
further afield
there are no local incentive schemes in
kent to encourage healthcare
professionals to come
to thanet and to turn thanit into one
unsightly urban sprawl will not entice
professionals when they could be
rewarded elsewhere with a better
environment
and better staffed medical facilities
it's also currently 46 000
nurse registered nurse vacant posts
vacancies go unfilled at the local
hospitals putting pressure on the
existing
workforce and stress and low paying
conditions
see a huge staff turnover
with this proposal and other
developments waiting in the wings
our local residents health needs cannot
be met with an
influx of new residents to misquote
a former prime minister there is no
magic
gp tree there is no magic
registered nursery to ensure the safety
and health needs of our residents i urge
the planning committee
to reject this developments application
thank you thank you for that council
gregory uh
speaking also as war counsellor council
of parents
thank you chair um along with my ward
residents i have many concerns about
this development including the loss of
arable land green spaces and our
valuable wildlife
and this last year has ensured we're all
very well aware
of the importance of green spaces to our
mental health and well-being
but the affordable housing quota has
been reduced to only 10 percent on this
development apparently down to the high
cost and complexity of the required
infrastructure drainage roads etc
due to so many difficulties involved in
building on this land
does this indicate that the land isn't
suitable for a housing development in
planet when we all know we need as much
affordable housing as
possible and it's sending a very risky
signal to future developers if we agree
to only 10
affordable housing whatever the reason
than it needs as much affordable housing
as possible
but i also want to question the basis of
the viability studies which support the
10
affordable housing the viability
assessment in annex one published last
june points out that due to the pandemic
transaction values and i quote have
fallen to unprecedented levels
and there is a demonstrable correlation
between such volumes falling
and a reduction in values the viability
assessment is predicated on
present day values
nearly a year ago we all know that the
housing market has improved considerably
since that time particularly the demand
for homes by the sea
so that an assessment undertaken nearly
a year ago must
be reviewed it may well reveal that 30
affordable housing is now viable and the
assessment actually states itself that
quote any improvement in the sales value
assumptions
would most likely be reflected and in an
improvement in scheme
viability my second point
is i have to mention gp provision a few
different angles to councillor gregory
and residents are very concerned about
this this is the topic that comes up so
much so there was a meeting of the kent
and midway
clinical commissioning group the ccg
last week
and they actually said that the thanet
gp system was fragile
and was struggling with the low number
of gps now i've been asking the lines
and the ccg to prioritize attracting
more gps to planet
for the last two years they tell me
they've tried everything and it's been
impossible
the ccg has steadfastly refused to
consider offering incentives they say
they can't such as enhanced payments or
golden handshakes
um any sort of incentives that we could
encourage more gps to plan it
hasn't been taken up um specifically the
lines in margaret has approximately 5
000 patients per gp
compared to a national average of
eighteen hundred
nearly three times as much this proposed
development on top of the other new
250 houses planned for samsung
is in the lime's catchment area they say
there will be a thousand and eighty new
patients
based on an occupancy of only 2.4 people
per dwelling
the developers can contribute to an
extension of the lines
but how are they going to recruit more
doctors
that is the crucial question we simply
cannot agree
to our population increasing overall
in planet by up to 50 000 people without
any more medical provision
councillor gregory has talked about the
hospital angle of this
also of course vital so we must insist
that the kent and medway ccg
take action to address the shortage of
gps in summit
before any more housing developments can
be agreed
i therefore ask you to reject this
application
or at least ensure that such a major
decision for thanet
is not delegated to officers but comes
back to our elected members
on the planning committee thank you
chair
thank you thank you very much councillor
parents um and i call upon
council boyd who is speaking under
council procedure
20.1 uh councillor boyd
thank you chair and thank you for
letting me um speak i'll be brief as
much as possible
and i'm here today basically because i'm
quite concerned about
um how much green infrastructure is
going to be impeded and have the lack of
green infrastructure
and placed into this plan and
the fields actually back onto my house
so i see it every day
and obviously it backs onto my wall
personally
um there is a very good separation of
settlements
where this land is and i think it's fair
to say that piece of glass
and the residents there do not feel part
of the suburb
do not feel part of the town and i think
this will merge the barriers
quite considerably and my colleagues
have already mentioned
things about wildlife and it's quite a
dark area the
um health and well-being of the bats is
quite a concern
and but also went to the well-being of
ourselves so being able to use cycle
paths
and being able to go on those walks the
design itself although they said yes
we've got green land
and just to simply put a different patch
of greenland in the corner of the
development is not good enough because
you've still got a built-up area
around all of that plans and something
else i would pick up on is
where you've got a children's play area
great which is over overlooked by
all of these houses but what about the
teenagers
and all you're going to get is a lot of
gathering because it's not going to be
good enough it's not
substantial there's big cries out now
for stuff for teenagers to do in margate
for example skate parks and all sorts of
stuff like that and this plan
simply does not cover it and so i think
it's quite
um unfair for it to be passed oh it's
okay because we've got something to five
to eight year olds
and because at the end of the day you're
just going to get people that live there
with teenagers
who have got nowhere else to go so
they're going to sit there they're not
going to cause any harm
but those residents overlooking the play
area will then start calling us up to
complain
and thinking that it's on social
behavior when frankly
there's nothing else for them to do and
so they're going to be victimized in
that respect
um but i just think that it's quite a
shame that we are looking at
getting rid of our green areas and and
having that divide particularly when we
look at green votes between weddings
which are protected in other areas of
spanish why are they not protected over
in this little corner
so that's that's all i've got today and
i'll pass over to the next person thank
you very much
thank you very much councillor boyd i
now called upon the council of pew
uh who's going to speak under council
procedure 20.1
and also if i may i do know that
uh councillor pugh and i believe other
members of the committee are aware
council review has been given a
statement
which i have allowed for part of it to
be
read out so council pew
yes thank you chair um and good evening
to members
of the planning committee um i'll try
and be brief
um i understand that this is going to be
a long meeting um but of course it's
important that you hear
not only my views but the views of my
residents um
to provide some context uh this site uh
borders my ward um saying that
you know almost all wards boarded the
fanuc villages ward nonetheless
um as council of heart will attest to
but
most importantly there's a small section
just south of this site
where there's a collection of houses
those those residents there are my
residents in my ward
and some of them are gravely concerned
about this application for a variety of
reasons
particularly the adverse impact that
runoff water and flooding would have
of this development but i want to touch
on a few matters and a few issues
to begin with namely that i'm quite
greatly concerned that not only
is this planned education been submitted
for less than
the total number has been allocated
within the local plan um
with how much work went into the local
plan and how much a struggle that was
and the general strength of feeling that
residents have
with the allocated housing numbers for
it to not only be put forward for less
numbers
um and then uh for the applicant to
argue that the
affordable housing percentage should be
dropped from 30
to 10 i think quite honestly is an
outrage
you know particularly in an area where
we need more affordable housing
that's evident it's cl it's quite clear
we've already had
a re-examination on the application that
you all decided on
last week for minster where the
landowner or land applicant had
campaigned for a 10
affordable instead it was revised back
up to 30
what's most important is that with our
local plan and it's been muted with this
i'm sure
as it was muted with the the point was
made with the application in minster
last week
is that this land is included in the
local plan there's no doubt about that
no one is arguing anything other than
that of course
it's allocated in the local plan as a
strategic site we get that
however i think it's quite important the
plan inspector has accepted our local
plan
and it's accepted this site as well to
be allocated if it's developed
for 30 affordable housing so the fact
that this
applicant is now put forward only 10
affordable
i think is more than enough grounds to
refuse permission
i mean heck i'd go to say if you if you
accepted that you refused permission
right now i'd stop speaking
but um i'm going to use up all of my uh
my allocation i'm sure um
another point has been said is that yes
it is in the local plan well of course
this site is including the local plan
but surely we as councillors and you as
the committee we have a duty to ensure
that any application that's put forward
for this site is the best that it can be
and quite honestly i don't think this is
so regardless of whether it's in a local
plan
i think that we have a duty to ensure
that it's the best it is and because
this isn't i think that you should of
course
refuse it um namely as well and i think
something else that i mentioned before
but i'll mention again at this meeting
of the planning committee
is that we're not hitting our targets um
for the annual delivery of housing
that's clearly not
something that is our fault as to
council it's not
a failing that we've made because we're
granting permissions left right and
center for quite large considerable
sites
and we have thousands and thousands of
units that are waiting to be built um
but one thing that i'd like to draw to
the attention of the planning committee
is that
we annually are undelivering under
delivering our annual housing target
namely i think last year we only
delivered circa about 50
so you know the idea that we continue to
keep granting planning permission just
because this site is including the local
plan i think is nonsense
um and i think honestly we're not we're
doing a disservice to residents
not only that but close to this site and
some members will recall
uh around about this time last year i
think it was or in the summer or
september
um there was land close to the site that
was suggested by the council to be used
as as a site for a temporary
temporary traveler site um i think
particularly
the amount of strength of feeling that
was felt locally against that and the
reasons
for various reasons why it was then not
considered
i doubt very much that a new development
would take quite likely to potentially
be incited next to a temporary traveler
site in the same way that residents in
garnish and the villages
were concerned that that farmland was
being put forward for it
um namely that and this is something
that i i should have mentioned at the
beginning but i'll mention now
there was a petition that was started up
that i think all members of the planning
committee have
now been shared with this morning um
that was only started on friday
that i think really shows the strength
of feeling of local residents that they
do not want
this application to be well to be
granted permission
and in the space of three or four days i
think it's launched on friday
friday afternoon it's now got over 3 000
signatures
which is no small order over the space
of a weekend
i know it's locked down but i think that
that's incredibly important and that the
committee should take note of that
and finally and thank you chair for
allowing me to read out
part of a statement but a resident of
mine
jonathan tapp who was the owner of
hatfield farm
who have farmed this land for two three
hundred years
um i've got a section of his objection
which i believe
was already included as part of the
formal consultation process and which i
shared with members of the committee
just before this meeting so that you
have a full copy of it
but i'd like to share out his concerns
and i think it shares the frustration
that's felt
locally in that really this is just the
tip of the iceberg
and that if this application is granted
permission it can open up a whole swathe
of farmland
you know in the centre of than it that
would just be decimated and destroyed
not only by development
but by infrastructure improvements and
roads and
particularly what i would say is not
only the widening of chardonnay road
because there's sections along shot and
day road that you can't widen because
there's houses on both sides
um but also the cutting up of farmland
carving up a farmland
for council council pew
please would you come to the statement
please brilliant thank you thank you
chair i certainly will
so this is just an excerpt of um
of uh mr tap's statement this proposal
is in the wrong place
it is not delivering the correct social
infrastructure no jobs
leisure or culture it is completely car
dependent
it destroys productive farmland which
has a history of farming dating many
centuries before the romans arrived
it reduces the hunting area for many
raptor species here
including buzzers kestrels little owls
barn owls and more recently
red kites it reduces the area available
for hairs patches skylights and sparrows
it endangers the
viability of my farming business which
has been in the same family for two
centuries
it should be rejected thank you very
much
uh thank you council pew and i did let
you go on
there and i don't want other members to
think that they didn't have the
opportunity i would let
yourselves that concludes public
speaking
and speaking from
members of the public which members have
heard
now i'm going to hand over to officers
to give
their report um namely ian
livingston annabelle hemmins
and james wright who i mentioned earlier
on
is kcc highways so
um pass over to ian
thank you very much chair i'll just
present my screen
uh so i'll start off then i'll pass to
annabelle
and then we'll pass to james and then
come back to me at the end so hopefully
you can all
uh see the screen and the red line plan
so the application is for
outline planning permission including
matters of access for up to 450 houses
with road infrastructure open space
landscaping associated
works so the application site is
outlined in
red we have hearts down road to the
north shottandain road
bisecting the two parcels of land for
the site and manson road
uh in the south east here so particular
points to note and i'm sure members are
quite familiar with the location of the
site but
uh margate football club which obviously
was at planning committee last month
is at the top of the screen here uh we
have uh
coffinhouse corner as it's known here uh
to gregory's primary school here and the
uh
cemetery uh kremlin and the uh
the waste and recycling center is just
down to the south
adjacent to the site as well is the
margate cricket club which is here
so this is a satellite image just to put
some some color on that so again you can
see that the cricket club the football
club
the primary school and the cemetery so
we're looking at
uh this site here uh and
this bit of land here so between the two
roads
on there and the two roads here
so this is a plan from the local plan
um so the allocation of the site is
outlined in the dotted red
here so the two sections are allocated
um
for up to 550 dwellings
that's under a specific policy which is
policy
sp 21. the policy itself outlines very
specific requirements
for the development of this site um they
are
provided on page 44 of the agenda
that's before you members um the
importance of this particular allocation
relates to the strategic routes through
the site
and they are the ones in yellow here
these are specifically allocated
in policy sp 47 uh
and with particular note is the the
vital part of the inner circuit
to support development in the district
as part of the local plan and the
delivery of housing
to 2031 uh from the arms here that go
through this site in particular
and obviously we can see here that it
actually includes as well
part of shandong road so
the principal issues of this site being
developed for housing
were considered in the local plan
examination and the adoption process
which considered the loss of
agricultural land across the district
when it came to the strategic allocated
housing sites as well as considering the
sustainability of this site to come
forward
for housing and the site is obviously
now allocated for housing
and therefore the principle of
development of this site has been agreed
through the local plan adoption process
and the issue for members is not whether
or not the site provides housing
it's how the site is developed for
housing
and looking specifically at policy sp21
so i'm going to go through a few views
of the site now so
to orientate members on this this is a
3d modeling that's come from
google on the bottom right hand side of
the image here
is the entrance the car park for margate
football club
and the cricket club is on the left-hand
side here
so this is the field that is the
northern
parcel of land so you can see that it's
currently
has a trees that line the site which is
on the northern boundary
trees that surround the cricket club and
some properties here
in this corner as well and you can see
shot and dane road
in the the very top of the image running
along here
what we're now going to look at is a
view from the houses that
are on schlondine road which is
mentioned by by councillor pugh we're
going to look
now towards the two parcels of land of
the site using the same 3d modeling from
from google
so this shows that the houses
are mentioned uh so we've got the
northern parcel of land
on the left-hand side of the image here
and again you can see the trees running
around the side of the moment
have shot and dane road here running
through the site
and then you have the southern section
of land
which is here so which with manston road
along the right hand side here with uh
the the cemetery
um particular point to note on this site
is if this is
an image that it shows um very clearly
the change in levels that occur across
the site which i'm going to talk
talk about in a second um you can see
there's a very dramatic change
from the shandong road up to the mansion
road which you can
you can obviously see here in this image
and then we're just going to look at a
view across manston road
using the same uh the same views
so this is a view just showing that
field as part of the allocation
shot and down road running across this
area here in the in the center of the
image
so we're now going to have a little look
at the at the existing landscaping on
site so this is
just a plan showing the existing trees
that are situated on the site so this is
useful to inform the photos that i'm
about to show you which show the
on the ground relationship between the
road network and the site
so you can see um some of the trees that
that ran along
the the northern boundary of the site uh
from hearthstone road
at the end of the site um where it uh
abuts the next field
and then scattered trees along
shotenbane road and along manchester
road
so starting at heartstown road and i'm
sure members will be familiar with this
view
going down heartstown road so this is a
view down towards the cricket club at
the bottom of the hill
and so the site is on the right hand
side here it's just after this hedge
so looking into the site this on the
right hand side of the image is the
trees that we saw in the 3d image
and the trees on the left hand side here
are the ones along the side of the
cricket club and we'll look at a
detailed view
you can start to see the change in
levels that occur across the site here
so we're higher up here the land slopes
down
to adjacent to the cricket club and you
can see then
there's uh there's schondane road in the
background and you can see the hill
where manson road is this is just a
bit of a closer view to show the the
trees along the boundary with the
cricket club
uh then looking from shot and dane road
so looking back towards where we were
just taking the photos from
so arlington house is in the background
of this image right in the center
so this is a view from shutting down
road so these are the trees that are
behind the houses
that that are behind the cricket club um
and you can see that the bank of trees
that i mentioned
um along that run from heartstown road
all the way along the northern boundary
of the site
these trees along the northern boundary
are all proposed to be retained as part
of the scheme as are the trees
on the right hand side of the image and
then turning to your left from
shotgundane road looking towards the
southwest boundary of the northern
parcel of land
you can see that it's a hedgerow line at
the moment apologies a slight dark image
but you can see that there is some sense
of a boundary there at the moment of the
site
and then turning to the other side of
shondane road
where you can see that there is a bank
of trees at the moment some of these
trees
are proposed to be lost as part of the
highway alignment that's proposed as
part of the
strategic route that that will change uh
but we'll look at that in a bit more
detail
in a little bit and then last set of
images
um looking from manston road here back
across to shondane road so looking to
the
the north west so this is a view from
um from manchester road looking towards
the site um you can see here quite
dramatically the change in levels that
occurs
um the field that you can see over the
brow of this hill is not the application
site it's the site to the north of that
the top of these trees
here in the center of the image are the
trees to be retained
as part of the development site on the
northern boundary
so you can see quite the extent of level
change including the very tops of street
lights where the mouse pointer is here
and obviously the change you can see the
properties that are actually fronting
shot and down road
uh obviously you can only see the roofs
of those properties there is quite a
significant
land level difference and that's been
reflected in the site constraints and
the way that the application site has
come
forward for development so this is a
plan showing the topography
of the land and the red line denotes the
application
site in particular
[Music]
so every line here is a five meter
difference
so at the lowest point of the land on
area a
so where the whiter area is you're
looking about four meters above
ordinance datum
the maximum that you get up to is 31
meters above ordnance datum
which is up on manston road and so you
can see these lines denoting a five
meter difference
show a dramatic change across from one
part of the site to the other
and as members will have seen it
requires a road to be
provided through this to connect to shot
and dane road to then connect
to hearthstone road and that has had a
significant abnormal cost
in terms of excavation and engineering
costs for the required road
infrastructure
and housing it's also resulted in a loss
of developmental land
now one of the things that's also come
about from the work that the applicants
has provided and looked into is one that
i know has been mentioned as a
particular concern
and that relates to flooding this has
been looked at in quite a lot of detail
by both
the applicant in their submissions but
also subsequently by officers and
consultees
so this is the plan to show surface
water flooding
across the site the dark blue is where
it's been
considered there is a potential high
risk of flooding so you can see the area
where it runs off the field down to that
lowest part of the site that we were
talking about into this area here with
further surface water
risk admittedly low risk but still risk
of surface water flooding here
now what that's meant is that the
development has to plan for potentially
a one in 30 year event
uh this information um you know has been
provided
by the applicant running a surface water
model um to look at this and therefore
the layouts had to accommodate both the
existing flows
but also accommodate a sustainable
drainage system
and a strategy for controlling those
flows
and we'll look at the particular
provision that's been made with regards
to attenuation basins
as well but obviously it has meant that
um some of this site cannot be
developed for housing because of the
surface water flows
in this site and that does can present
site constraints in terms of
the land take for for numbers of houses
as well as that and coming up in terms
of uh the detailed work that's done
after a site is allocated
uh is in this area here so in the the
south uh the southeast corner of the
site
um work was done specifically with
regards to trial trenching following
geophysical
survey work done for archaeology uh in
consultation with kcc archaeology
and the trial trenching that was carried
out uh has confirmed the need for an
exclusion area
in the the bottom southwest corner of
the site
where preservation in situ of
archaeological remains is required
and therefore there is no development
that's proposed within
the archaeological exclusion zone which
you can see in the in the
right hand side here which part of the
site we are looking at with the the map
on the right
with the uh with the exclusion zone at
the
the sort of very full extent of that
area
b um and these constraints have resulted
in the application site coming forward
for less houses uh than is allocated so
less dwellings than is allocated in
in the uh in the local plan allocation
um so i'm now going to pass over to
annabelle
who's going to outline the detail of the
proposal
thank you
hopefully members can see the screen now
we can
sorry i need to go back
bear with me i've come too far
sorry members bear with me
so i remember just waiting for the
presentation to reload
so hopefully members can now see a plan
apologies for that um um
ian's explained some of the context um
and seeing we've seen some views
surrounding the site and i'm going to
try and take members through the
proposal that is now before us
um i will remind members that it is an
outline application for up to 450
dwellings
with only access to be considered at
this time
so any points of access onto the site
all other matters so appearance layout
scale and landscaping
are reserved for future consideration
but as with other outline applications
of this sort of scale and nature
parameter plans and indicative mask
plans have been submitted
to inform the reserve matters
applications that will
come forward if this application is
granted
and they provide um
details that those um reserve matters
would have to record and
have regard to this parameter plan
is the combined pla parameter plan that
is mentioned in condition six
which brings together a number of the
individual parameter plans are being
submitted with the application
and as i say this plan together with a
landscape strategy plan
is the plan that's referred to in
condition six
and it sets out the parameter principles
and parameters
for the subsequent subsequent reserve
matters
um to follow and adhere to
it's quite a busy plan but to just give
you some
um points on this but we will look at
individual
upper parameter plans that come forward
um we have here the routes coming
through so this would be shorter down
up from manston road and through to
hearthstone road
the cricket club the football club is
off
on just off of the slide here on the
other side of heartstown road
we have the cemetery and we can also see
the archaeological exclusion zone that
ian has just mentioned so moving on
this is the building heights parameter
plan so it's taken
one of the aspects that we've seen on
the previous plan
and of course we as an outline we don't
have details of house designs
or appearance or scale in
full detail at this stage but this does
identify proposed building heights the
majority of building heights and this is
this
pale yellow color here and
running along the north of the site here
will be up to two stories in height
the darker yellow so more centrally here
and some bits running off towards
hearthstone road
would be up to two and a half stories
and the orange color which is pretty
much in the center
here would be up to three stories in
height
and it's noted that the three-story
elements or
elements up to three story are located
centrally
centrally within sight and around
features such as the main road
and open space which we'll see in the
future parameter plans
and they are also at the on the lower
level of the site and we've seen
from ian's presentation the considerable
change in the land level
between the north area a on this slide
and area b
of the application sites and all
officers consider this approach reflects
scale and pattern of existing
development in the area
which is a mix of two story mainly with
some
development in the roof and some
bungalows
so moving on to another plan that's been
submitted
and this plan shows proposed areas of
open space
um within the application site the
requirement for open space within the
allocation is for a minimum
of 4.4 hectares spread across the two
parts of the site
um but it needs to be accessible from
both sides
this application actually proposes some
6.3 hectares of open space
and as you can see from the
um slide it is actually spread
throughout
the application site and does contain a
mix of formal informal spaces
you may recall seeing um from ian's
presentation
the area that wasn't particularly
affected by surface water
and this is the bit that runs through
from here
and right across this sort of central
area of the plan
and if this is actually being developed
not as
building land but would provide a linear
park through the site
and it includes
as part of the sustainable drainage
schemes
things like attenuation basins
um which would be also a landscape
feature in its own right
there are two equipped areas of play
which is the leaps here
so there's one within the central linear
park and another one
and this lower level of the high level
but in the south of the site
near manston park there are also enough
of six
local areas of play they are more
informal and not equipped but they do
still provide
opportunities for play space
the archaeological exclusion zone is
located in this area here
and as has been mentioned this is
actually for archaeological
preservation in situ so it would
actually be landscaped only and would
not be accessible to the public but it
still provides
a valuable amount of open space that
could be landscaped
excuse me there is also an area here
this grey triangle
which is a land that is safeguarded to
allow
flexibility for the alignment of shot
and down road because
it's the tr the proposed allocation has
not been set as yet so that land is
safeguarded
for that purpose
and this plan is an extract from the
agricultural impact
assessment which was submitted to
support the application
the purple notations are trees
and hedges and groups of trees that are
to be retained within the application
the red
areas are actually trees that would be
lost um
within lost in the proposal
and it can as it can be seen that these
are
along the shot and down road route
and also in the area
adjacent heartstand road and these would
be lost
as a result of the need for access
and for the realignment of shot and down
road but it can be seen that there will
be a large number
of the majority of trees here will be
retained
this is actually quite a detailed plan
with a lot of information on
it but it is the landscape strategy plan
which is the second plan which is named
in condition six which all reserve
matters
applications would have to accord with
so this highlights areas for additional
tree and hedge planting
throughout the street uh throughout the
site and including along
road boundaries within proposed open
spaces for example here
adjacent to manston road and in the
linear park itself
and also to the boundaries of the site
and there is also protection for some
protected trees that lie along the side
of
the cricket club it also
is a detailed plan that includes um
details of native siege
species of trees and planting
appropriate for the different areas of
the site
it also includes details of ecological
enhancements that will come forward
throughout the site and also
makes commitments to play provision as
we've seen in the previous slides with
the leaps and the laps and recreational
paths and cycleways
it also along this route is
t footpath tm14 which is required to be
requained
under the allocation and also
links to be provided onto it and this
application does provide for all of
those
all of that to take place
this slide is the development framework
plan
so again we can see areas
of proposed open space the main access
routes that would be proposed through
the site
and this together with smaller roads and
connections off
within the sort of developable area that
would come forward
i would like to draw members attention
particularly though to the yellow
asterisks around the plan
and these are actually heritage sites um
adjoining or nearby
the application site so we have the
cemetery
here with several listed and
non-designated heritage assets
within it we have samsung grange
over here which is grade two star listed
we have shot and dane nursing home here
which is grade two listed
and we also have the farm house within
the complex of shot and down farm which
is also grade two listed
obviously again we do not have the finer
detail of the application because it is
an outlined form
but it is recognized um
that there would be some impact on
heritage assets by the development of
this site for residential or in for any
other use
but it is considered and but this would
have been considered in detail when the
site was put forward for allocation
through the local plan process
um in when looking at this application
the detail we do have before us it is
considered the applicants have sought to
minimize the impact as much as possible
um at this stage given that we are
looking at
an outline application
there are open space buffers to certain
areas of the site
and it is noticed that
[Music]
the nearest
residential developments are in air to
the heritage assets would be the two
up to two-storey development with the
larger
taller developments being within the
center of the site
so away from the heritage assets
surrounding it
so this is actually the indicative
master plan
um which shows the layout or a layout of
the site
showing how the 450 dwellings could be
accommodated
with all the other requirements such as
open space new roads
and including the realigned link road
again the application site as you can
see is here
and this is essentially an l shape
proposed development would have a gross
density of 23 dwellings per hectare
over the whole site and a net density of
34 dwellings per hectare
if we just consider the developer
developable area of the site
i.e not the open space and
roads and office spaces that are
required
this is considered to be acceptable in
that it would be sympathetic in terms of
density to
the area's rural setting and surrounding
development
in terms of living conditions again we
don't know the details of the
site um the nearest
residential development is in this
location here
we have some uh schottendone road a shop
sorry at shuttledown farm here
and various other development on
shotstone road and manson road itself
the parameter plans do however show that
landscaping is proposed to the edge of
the site and that would be enhanced for
tree planting and hedge planting
and there is increased separation
distance it sorry then there are
this provides a landscape buffer between
the site boundaries and the built form
within the new um development
um it is also noted that height
parameters
propose the areas to the edges of the
site would be
up to two stories in height in the vast
majority
so the detailed consideration of
the relationship between surrounding
properties and
existing properties would come forward
at
reserve matter stage but it is
considered that this is a good starting
point and
the limitations that we do have and
content of the parameter plans that are
before us and we are
conditioning will give some comfort that
we would be able to
mitigate as much as possible impact on
adjoining residential
occupiers and lastly given the scale and
nature of the application site
it is considered that development could
be secured
um at the reserve matters state it will
provide a high standard of accommodation
for future occupiers
thank you chair i'll now pass back to
ian
thank you annabelle i'll just present my
screen um
and then i will
introduce uh james branson kcc
highways who's going to talk through the
slides um
in regards to uh the highway uh part of
this development so i'll just pass over
to james
yeah thank you uh mr livingston yeah i'm
james ray i'm the
principal transport and development
planner for the fannie and diver areas
for kent county council
i was involved in the uh development of
the uh fanuc transport strategy
in collaboration with district council
on your screen there i thought it'd be
very useful for me to give you an
oversight as to how this planning
application
site sits within the framework of the
transport strategy
hopefully members can see that on the
screen relatively blurry for me on my
screen but hopefully
it's good enough for you to decide for
where we are um the phantom transport
strategy uh just to give you an update
is in its current draft is uh fully
endorsed by fanuc
joint transportation board banner
district council and
obviously kent county council it was
included
in the local plan evidence base it was a
supporting document to the local plan
which was recently
examined the planning inspector
had extended discussions over the uh the
transport strategy and it after that
extended dialogue it was found to be
sound
um there was a lot of scrutiny over the
transport strategy uh but in the end the
the uh
um inspector was uh satisfied that it
was a
sound strategy to support the local plan
and the uh
development that's planned within it um
the two main themes within the transport
strategy
are improving network resilience and
managing journey times so in terms of
improving resilience that means giving
more routes for traffic to disperse
providing those additional routes so
that when you get somebody
mentioned earlier about seasonal peaks
you've got more routes in and out of
vanet
everybody knows what happens in fanet um
when something happens on the a28
the whole of that side of the district
grinds to a
grinding halt and the idea of the
transport trust is to provide that
additional resilience
the primary piece of infrastructure
within the transport strategy is the
creation of the inner circuit that was
mentioned earlier by one of the speakers
um in time this will create a improved
route of the highway links
and that will complement the existing
primary road network so
on the screen there you've got to the um
west of the
district you've got a link road between
the a28
and a cole hill through the strategic
virtual development
an upgrade to the existing manson road
between a cole hill
and schottendame road with associated
drunk junction improvements
and then an upgrade to the existing shot
and dame road corridor
all the way down to the application site
with associated junction improvements
at minster road high street garland
and then obviously at the application um
site end you've got the
the the two roads forking off uh one
between
shot and dame road and hearts down road
and shot and dame road
and manston road and that doves tails in
nicely with the um
application that came before you
recently for development on
the site between nash road and manston
road which will also provide a new link
road
as sites come forward nash road itself
will be upgraded
um there'll be a requirement for all of
these roads to be
delivered to a local distributor
standard so local distributor standard
basically means
wide enough to accommodate all types of
traffic that might use them
uh they will include footway cycle ways
um and
and will be high quality infrastructure
and will hopefully provide
a much needed um additional amount of
connectivity between the settlements
within planet
um in terms of the application sites um
a key part
of the local plan and transport planet
transport strategy
is the resilience and this provides it
around the coffin house corner junction
um through the delivery of on-site
infrastructure and financial
contributions which have been outlined
within the offices report
um the traffic modelling so in terms of
the the plan you've got on the screen
there
the two link roads will basically enable
traffic to bypass
some of the traffic to bypass the coffin
house corner junction so anyone coming
along shot and dane road for example
that currently has to come down
and turn left along hearts down road
we'll no longer need to do that because
they can use the
northern link road um anybody coming
from
hearts down road towards um coffin house
corner and they want to access westward
cross
we'll be able to use the new link roads
to effectively bypass the congestion you
get at the moment at the coffin house
corner junction
and use the new upgrade in time we'll be
able to use the new upgraded
nash road corridor as part of the
um the other application on the nash
road manson road site
there will be a reconfiguration of the
coffinhouse corner junction
so the nash road arm will be stopped up
traffic will be forced along the new
link road
what that basically enables us to do is
to look at the configuration of the
coffin house corner junction
and optimize the amount of traffic that
you can get through there and
potentially provide a better pedestrian
experience as well near the school
the traffic modelling that we undertook
to support the local plank
includes that the inner circuit as a
whole will provide much needed
resilience within the local road network
it won't eradicate all the existing
traffic pressure
uh within the districts but it does
provide that resilience which was the
main
theme of the of the uh strategy um
the local junctions everybody knows that
that's a very busy junction there coffin
house corner it's always going to be
busy
you know it does provide a
distributed route for a lot of the
traffic within the district
um but what this you know plan will do
will help manage that growth so it
doesn't get
exponentially worse um clearly the
delivery of the
inner circuit as a whole is quite an
ambitious plan but i think it's
something that's really needed for
phanet
um generally got a strong level of
support locally
i think the old saying of like rome
wasn't built in a day
really applies here in terms of the
inner circuit um there's various pieces
of the jigsaw that need to be provided
um but they need to come forward as it
as as when each
strategic site comes forward through a
combination of on-site infrastructure
um and financial contributions enabling
the county council to deliver um
off-site
uh improvements along the schottendam
road corridor and the other sections
outside of the cartilage of the
development sites it wouldn't be
realistic to expect
the whole inner circuit to be delivered
on day one
um but it's essential that so any
funding that we do secure towards the
off-site sections of the inner circuit
need to be done on a flexible basis
so we need to be able to evolve you know
there's a local plan review coming up
we need any contributions that are
secured to be able to be used towards
this iteration of the inner circuit or
any any any changes in planning
circumstances that might happen across
the plan period
so we've we've hopefully secured secured
that through
the planning obligations that are
outlined within the report
and to speed up the delivery of the
transport strategy um
some members may have heard in the news
um that we've got a
uh external funding bid currently in
track
um through the major road network fund i
think the
um applicant statement mentioned that
mrn funding stream
so just to give you a little bit of an
outline as to what is encompassed within
the mrn bid
the major road network fund is a
specific fund from the department for
transport
um to help to manage traffic congestion
and pressure on the major road network
now the a28 is part of that network
so this fund is specifically focused
towards the a28 corridor
and what we can do to alleviate
congestion or to manage
growth in the future in terms of what it
includes
it includes the um lincr new junction on
to the a28
where where the um birchington site
would be
uh the new link road coming across to a
cole hill
um the new upgraded link of manston road
between ecole hill
and schottendame road the columbus
avenue extension which provides you
almost an a bypass as such um
upgrades to the existing uh shot and
dame road corridor up to the application
site
and then obviously the two link roads
within the application site as well so
that it's quite
key in terms there's a mention of
viability earlier and
an affordable housing provision um the
provision of external funding will have
a you know
provide a big boost to the um the
viability potentially on this site
um and we're obviously exploring
additional funding streams as and when
they come on track
so in in in essence it's really
essential that the the allocated housing
sites continue to be delivered
in vanit um because that will bolster
match funding for these these types of
bids and
will only bolster the the chances of
those bids been accepted by central
government
um however obviously we can't be
completely reliant upon a major road
network fund
um and for a sound local plan you have
to have infrastructure that can be
delivered on its own
thing so in the absence of the major
road network funding stream
we will explore additional funding
streams from elsewhere but the default
position is that the inner circuit needs
to be secured through the strategic
development sites and they need to fund
it all
um so when you look at you look at this
development site in
isolation um it will lead to
increases and decreases on the local
highway network
mentioned earlier about the the district
redistribution of traffic that
there are certain traffic movements that
won't have to go through the coffin
house corner
network obviously delivering these two
new link roads will make
shot and damn road a slightly more
attractive proposition for people
because they won't necessarily although
all of the people that are traveling on
shot and dave
won't necessarily get stuck at the
coffin house corner junction where
there's
you know a little bit of a delay in in
traffic movements through there
at the moment um there's likely to be a
net decrease
at coffin house corner when this
application actually comes in
um that's because obviously you take
you're taking away um potential
movements that would go through there
um so there'll be a small decrease in
traffic through the coffeehouse corner
junction but
obviously that will get soaked up by
additional development when it comes
forward um
sort of later on for some of some of the
other strategic developments
um there will be a small increase in
trafficking victoria traffic signals
um and on a few of the other junctions
um but obviously the delivery of these
two link roads will
help to manage some of the traffic
conditions within the a28 corridor
um and i think we really do need to look
at this um
holistically and on balance
so obviously looking at the application
at the moment
i would recommend the site needs to be
considered in the context of the
transport strategy
um the interim impacts that the
development will
generate aren't considered to be
objectionable
as proportionate funding towards the
inner circuit has been secured as part
of the application as outlined in the
offices report
and there's flexibility in how we can
apply that funding in the future if we
need to
um if we can move on to the next slide
um so this slide shows you the proposed
new junction this is uh on the
northern link road on the heart down
roadside
um so on hearts down road there will be
a requirement for a right turn lane
so what would the right turn lane will
do is it will allow traffic to
to queue to wait to turn right uh
without impeding traffic existing
traffic on the on the hearthstone road
network um the reason why we've gone for
a right turn lane here is because
you're you're not you're unlikely to get
that many right turners out of that
junction
um because anybody traveling along the
um half down road
sorry the shotgun road corridor will
obviously continue along that corridor
and unlike it's unlike to go down the
link road and turn right
um the link roads themselves um they're
earmarked at 6.7 metres wide minimum
um although obviously that's a reserve
matter the actual
standard of the of the road will be um
clarified through the reserve matters
and secured through that but there's
an expectation there will be a cycle way
on one side of footwear on the other
the road will be wide enough for buses
and larger vehicles to use
in in accordance with the requirement
for the inner circuit for it to be to
local distributor standard
uh we can move on to the next um slide
so this shows the central uh roundabout
on shot and dame road so it's a four
arm roundabout modeling modelling has
been done on this to show
that with in the 2027 scenario um which
has
been done for the development site it um
operates with
plenty of spare capacity so it should
take us through too easily to 2031.
um end of local plan um there is
the the documentation that was provided
with the application did show that there
is a
an element of speeding that takes place
on this this section of shot and dane
road it's quite a wide
corridor um and a 30 mile an hour limit
at the moment
um hopefully we would expect this um
this new road feature to help manage
those speeds on that link
next slide if possible
and then on to the manston road that
would be a free arm
roundabout again the junction capacity
has been checked there
um all of these junctions have been
subject to independent road safety
audits so that basically means the road
safety would have to
assess the designs and comment on them
um so we're satisfied with
with with the responses to those road
safety audits
um and uh as um
annabelle has outlined ms simmons as
outlined
we've also got the safeguarding of the
additional land on shot and dame road
um to facilitate flexibility over the
improvements to the remaining off-site
sections of shot and down road in the
future
so in summary we're satisfied that the
proposed development will positively
contribute towards the strategic aims
of the transport strategy and on balance
the residual traffic impacts from the
development aren't considered to be
severe in our in our view
thank you james um i'm just going to
outline to members um
some points to do with viability and
planning obligations and then i'll i'll
sum up
so i do appreciate that um that the
presentation has has gone on to just
give all the details to members
um so in terms of planning obligations
the report outlines
um page 67 onwards about planning
obligations and the heads of terms for
this
particular application um so
the allocated one of the site's um sort
of key features as mentioned is the
strategic infrastructure and that
policy requires that proportionate
contributions
must be made to off-site highways
infrastructure
from the strategic allocated sites as
well as that and obviously one of the
key policies that's discussed at length
is is policy sp 23 which is that the
target of 30
of all dwellings on site should be
affordable
for a development of this sort of scale
the specific policy criteria does state
that that can be reduced
if meeting uh those requirements
wouldn't that requirement would make the
development
unviable so the viability assessment was
submitted with the application this was
assessed by
dixon searle um who did our whole plan
val
viability work for the local plan they
also did the work on the minster housing
site which came with four members
last week where following the the
assessment that was made by both
officers and the independent assessment
um the council successfully agreed that
30
should be provided on that site
following the information
being assessed and submitted now this
site
um is different from other sites um very
specifically we've gone through the
specific constraints that this site has
and the additional abnormal costs
and but it's also not a situation that i
know members are concerned
about which we've had in the past comes
planning committee
specifically with regards to the samston
grange development that you can see on
the
on the right hand side here but also the
mansion green development
this is not a situation where um we've
we've already come to planning committee
and the site has promised 30 affordable
and then
we're coming back to look at a reduction
this was very clearly and transparently
put
up front as that there is a viability
issue with this site
due to the topography the drainage the
highway costs
uh which then lead to a reduction in the
number of units that the site can
provide so the annexes to the
the to the report include um the actual
viability
assessments that have been carried out
and and the back and forth as well
these are reviewed in page 68 of the
report
so the case that's put forward is for
10 affordable housing with an 80 20
split as mentioned earlier
with 4.9 million in total for
contributions covering
a variety of matters to do with
community and highways infrastructure
as well as specific mitigation towards
the the
um in terms of the actual detail of the
viability appraisal i'm just going to
briefly touch on a summary um the the
gross development value
um has been assessed um
one of the concerns that was raised is
when that gross development value was
assessed in terms of house prices
the assessment occurred towards the end
of last year so submitted in july but
the actual
assessment was done towards the end of
last year and i'll go into
one of the particular requirements
that's put in the heads of terms about a
review mechanism which will look at if
values do
go up and how that will increase the
provision of contributions
um the costs the developer costs
particularly regards this site have been
looked at in a lot of detail with an
independent
qs report separate from the independent
review of viability being done and
looked into
because of those abnormal engineering
costs and highways costs
that have come forward the level of
developer profit is considered to be
in accordance with the requirements that
we've put on all of our strategic
allocations of seventeen and a half
percent of gross development value um
and on the basis of this evidence which
has been looked at in a lot of detail
and considering specifically the mppg
guidance um you know it is recommended
that the viability
evidence should be given uh significant
weight
and that the site would be as the policy
requires the assessment of it would be
unviable
with more than the stated amount of
affordable housing
and the contributions so on those
contributions
of the 4.9 million it is proposed to
ring fence the contribution towards the
strategic access management monitoring
plan so that's the
mitigation for the impact on the
designated sites at south coast and
pedwell area
but also to ring fence the specific
contribution towards health care
that's already been mentioned which is
been requested specifically by the ccg
on their specific methodology to
calculate what the contribution
should be from a residential development
and that's 388
000 ring fenced for for that purpose
the rest of the money to be provided on
a per unit basis up to a total of 4.3
million approximately is to be collected
into an infrastructure pot to be used
towards the identified uh projects that
are outlined
on page 72 of the report
upon agreement between tdc and kcc so
the money comes to
tdc as local planning authority and can
be used on a flexible basis towards
those
specific projects when they are most
needed because certain projects
can come forward at different times
obviously it's been mentioned about
external funding
and when that needs maybe needs to be
applied for highway infrastructure
as well as when money is needed to
provide for example
the new secondary school in margate
it is considered that this contribution
package is sufficient to mitigate the
impact of development
to be in accordance with policy at sp
41 of the local plan um but
obviously this is an outline application
so it is important
that um whilst we're agreeing a position
now
that there is the potential that things
could change into the future and
obviously what's been touched on already
is about the
major road network funding as well as
potential that values go up and costs go
down
um on that basis is considered
appropriate and necessary
for two specific review mechanisms
within the section 106
based specifically on site viability
to secure one to secure part of the
surplus any surplus that's created
part of that when the values go up and
costs go down
um that money is secured towards
off-site
affordable housing uh there are two
trigger points
for that chain for that assessment one
is prior to the occupation
of the 200th dwelling on the site and
another one would be prior to the
occupation of the 400th dwelling on the
site
hales values that actually come out of
the scheme
and as already mentioned kcc have a live
bid for major road network funding with
funding with the department of transport
um
that funding if it came to comes to pass
would pay for the majority of costs of
the roundabouts and the road
upgrades within this site with some
match funding needed
from the developer um and therefore we
need a review mechanism
uh so that if the grant comes in and kcc
provide these roads
that the money saved by the developer
comes to the council
uh to be spent on the projects that are
outlined
in the heads of terms including offsite
affordable housing as well as
highway off-site other highway
infrastructure education
and so on as outlined this plan in front
of you shows the indicative phasing plan
that's proposed for development so
you'll see that the green here is
1a which includes the junction on the
heartstown road
as well as the roundabout on schattenden
road to be provided
within the first phase of the scheme
with the roundabout on manchester road
being provided in the second
well 1b phase of the scheme
now there is a plan that requires a
highways works phasing plan
specifically to come in to look at the
precise
timing of when these junction works and
these new roads need to be provided
linked to the occupancy of the units
they're in conditions 20
and 21 and just to
obviously does include then the later
phases here which includes the last bit
of the shot and
road and obviously the safeguarded land
that's in this area in the last phase
you know if it comes forward as in and
is necessary by kcc
so
in in conclusion um the site
is allocated housing site it's required
to deliver
housing and infrastructure as a key part
of the authentic local plan strategy
the applicant has designed around the
constraints of this site looking at
surface water drainage archaeology the
required highways links
providing open space adjacent to
heritage assets
as well as safeguarding particular land
as necessary
and that has led to a reduction in the
number of
units that's proposed to 450
the scheme shows an enhancement to the
biodiversity potential of this site
above existing and that's been agreed
and commented on by kcc biodiversity as
well as dealing with surface water
flooding
um and that has been agreed by kcc
as the lead flood authority um planning
obligations have been looked at in a lot
of detail
on this application and the 10
affordable housing
which has been clearly evidence will
provide social benefit as well as this
the pot and it is considered there are
specific
reasons why we can agree it at this
level
i do not agree that it could that it
actually would
would lead to a assumption that this is
a a normal
uh case of events it's always looked at
very specifically and that's just
demonstrated by last week
when we were talking about minster when
it was secured at 30
even with um the submissions that were
made for less
and fundamentally this this development
side does provide key infrastructure in
the district which is
is does need to be given significant
weight as well as providing allocated
housing
when the council is in a uh presumption
in favor of sustainable development
and therefore the application is
recommended to be deferred for approval
and that's subject to receipt of the
section 106
specifically providing the required
heads of terms as outlined in the report
and with the safeguarded conditions uh
imposed on the decision which are at the
top
of the gender item thank you chair
uh thank you ann uh just like to thank
all officers um
and uh kcc as well very detailed report
there for members
as usual i'm going to recommend that the
officer's
recommend recommendation is adopted
could the vice chair
please second or second nature
uh thank you councillor coleman cook and
i have speakers
uh no councillor allman's been on there
since just after six o'clock um
but your turn now cancer album
thank you chair two things one i've got
a question i'd like to ask that first
can the officers advise uh if the
developer
owns the land please
can and can i come back to win on that
or
um i believe the developer has um an
option on the land
um to to buy the land as for ownership i
would have to double check the
application form but i believe it's an
option on the land specifically
thank you okay thank you um
reason i ask that chair is obviously if
the if the developers
are submitting an application on land
that they don't own then the the land
owner
which which can happen and does happen
uh then the land owner can obviously
then
refuse them the right to build on the
land so that's just
that's just one that's that's just one
thing um
my my comments chair are that um
i think we need to consider the human
cost of this
um whilst it's clear
that within the local plan this area of
land is designated
for housing
and the council has approved that
uh so it's it's not what should be built
it's
as mr livingston said it's how it's how
it should be actually built and the
effect of that
on our community um
the effects of it for me is i am
extremely disheartened
uh in relation to
a ten percent of full affordable housing
i know
uh mr livingston has outlined the
reasons why
however uh my my view is
that it is unacceptable uh
it's clear policy 30 affordable housing
and um
if they can't afford that and to build
it then don't build the
development um
i also have concerns about the highway
issues
um whilst it's good to see
uh the uh roundabouts to go in
and and the routes through the actual
development site
uh mr ray has clearly said that it's not
going to really alleviate
in any major way the coffin house corner
issues you know i've i've regularly gone
down
uh manston road from ramsgate into
margate
and especially on a weekend and uh to
get a manson road to get on the shot and
dane road and then go further
you know i've i've been stuck there half
an hour
uh when there's only been approximately
20 cars trying to get out of madison
road into shotendome road
um so and on top of this
obviously we're going to have 450 houses
with all that traffic that it demands
there of course is a social impact
of this development upon the um
upon the area and that relates to and
that relates to
what uh two of our uh
fellow councillors have raised in
relation to the health issues
um that again should concern us all
about the weight of that about the
weight that's that's put on our
surgeries uh as some of us know
sometimes it takes two weeks to get an
appointment but
um well she may say that that's not
really relevant to this development
it is all developments cause these
issues
um also um
large developments that the government
are requiring us to actually
have and let's not forget that the
government have said that we've got to
have
these amount of houses in our area
and we are now taking up arable land
for our area to put these houses upon
we all find that difficult but
unfortunately the government is making
us do
this um it doesn't sit comfortable with
us
you know we don't we don't actually want
to do it but
um we're left with no alternative
in relation to these sites being
confirmed as housing sites
so in principle uh
we should actually approve this because
it's a housing development site
they come up with less than the 550
houses to go on the site that's that's
shown that
it could be and in principle we should
support that
however i cannot support i cannot
support it
in relation to both the affordable
housing
and to the effects of what i can see to
be on
the road transport network because mr
ray
says this isn't going to happen
overnight this is going to take
some while to actually take place and
the impacts of that upon our local roads
and which will affect the air quality
which which will affect uh
local businesses etc etc is uh
is not good enough for me so chairman uh
my my view is that i cannot support this
application
as is thank you uh thank you
councilwoman before i bring in
mr livingston uh uh i've got to say this
um
members who have spoken on 20.1
and thank you councillor for pointing
this out um i would ask you not
to comment on the chat line um totally
understand
uh your feelings um and obviously you
had the opportunity earlier
but the chat line is for members of the
the committee and
officers um if you could please accept
that
thank you uh councillor hart sorry uh
ian
you wanted to come back sorry thank you
thank you and i
appreciate you letting me come back
after a long presentation um
i just wanted to pick up a couple points
because um the council organs raised
um one relates to the the first points
to about 10 affordable housing
um obviously we've provided the
detailed information that both submitted
by the applicant and also the report
that's been provided by the independent
consultants that we use
um and it is important to consider that
evidence
in coming to a decision about whether or
not to accept less
than the 30 and it's understood that
that is always difficult and as i've
outlined
to this committee a number of times we
will always look to see the absolute
maximum
that is possible um but there are
situations where
sites um cannot come forward with a 30
affordable um contribution um
i i mean i'll give an example of one
it's not in this district that came
before planning committee
in a neighboring district in canterbury
very recently for an allocated housing
site for 630 houses
providing eight million odd towards um
a a link road um where zero percent
affordable housing
was provided and that was agreed and
approved and it was on the basis of the
evidence that's there now
we're in fanat and we want to get as
much affordable housing as possible
um and it is always important that we
we assess in a lot of detail the
evidence that's been provided but we
have to give it
weight when considering whether or not
the development should be allowed or not
at less than the policy requirement
and in this instance officers have put
it forward on the basis of approval
if the amount of affordable housing were
to go up
uh that deducts money for the other
contributions with regards to this
scheme
it is been demonstrated quite clearly it
would be unviable
at any more contributions or with more
affordable housing
and it is obviously i've mentioned an
allocated site which does bring forward
needed housing in the district um there
are the review mechanisms which are very
specifically in there to try and capture
any improvements um i did i might want
to just bring in
james um with regards to the the roads
uh
network point if that's okay but just on
my side of things
it's important that the highway
infrastructure that's being proposed on
this site
um in the long term would again give
that network resilience that's important
in the local plan
in terms of the strategy of how these
all these housing sites get delivered
but it is about this scheme and this
number of houses
um does the provision of highway works
that's been provided
support this development of 450 houses
to ensure that these 450 units do not
have a severe
impact on the highway network and in
the view of kcc not want to put words in
enough it wouldn't result in a severe
harm
to the network so it's not going to be
considered from the officer's view
to be a reason for refusal that would
stand up in an appeal situation
and i did want to pick up one point
about air quality because we didn't
cover in the presentation
but there is a lot of work again that's
gone into air quality there was an air
quality assessment that was submitted
with the application
it's been looked at by the environmental
health team
we are requiring an emissions mitigation
assessment to be provided
prior to the reserve matters which will
outline a combination of measures
including
damage costs that need to be spent on
site to improve air quality there are
electric vehicle charging points
and there are very specific grasslands
that are being proposed within
the ecology and sort of and landscaping
plan
out specifically to offset nitrogen from
cars so we do consider that point
particularly has been
has been dealt with um james i don't
know whether or not you've got any
comments on the highway side of things
yeah i'll comment on that um perhaps i
wasn't clear enough in my presentation
regarding this
site specifically on its own merits um i
think if you look at this site it's
450 dwellings it will generate in
general
around 260 movements that's comings and
goings
combined on the local road network
there's five there's five
potential routes out from the
development site on the local network so
it will
distribute out onto a number of routes
within the local network
the modeling that was done to support
the application does suggest that there
would be
i say a positive impact at the coffin
house corner junction
um because the delivery of the link
roads will take traffic off
um so obviously in time there will be
more more growth within the local
uh plan that comes forward and that will
soak up um
that capacity that's released by this
site but if you're simply looking at
this site on its own merits on its own
and taking it to an appeal i think you'd
find it very difficult to actually
demonstrate
the on balance when you take into
account all the benefits that the
development provides and the
proportionate contribution towards the
wider strategy and the fact that
the adopted transport strategy clearly
says that resilience is you know one of
the key drivers
um for the planet road network moving
forward i think you'd find it very
difficult to defend that position
um and that you know obviously this this
issue in terms of the local plan
the inspector did consider the
infrastructure uh delivery plan
and this was a clear part of that and
was satisfied that was a sound plan
so i i would i would encourage members
um to consider that when they're making
their decision
uh thank you for that james um counselor
heart
thank you chair it's been a very
interesting and um
informative meeting and i think it's
been done very well by the officers
involved
um i do have a few comments and a few
things to say
um i'm concerned about i read in and i
don't understand it in so you will have
to explain it to me
um it had on page uh what was it page 38
something called colluvia which i have
had to have a lot of look into
because i had no idea what that was and
that was
to do with the movement of land um and
therefore
it travels down the site and so
therefore you have
it's basically filling in a riverbed or
whatever can be used as another way but
i think that's alluvium i'm not too sure
i've got a bit confused on it now i
don't know if that's historic
i don't know if it's continual i don't
know
if the buildings that will go on will
have to then be
on stilts and i don't know if that will
affect the whole site in any way
shape or form one assumes it may do
because it's going to travel down the
sides of the
um field into the middle which is what i
assume happens
now also i don't really
i would like to know what's going to
happen with tivoli brooke
can they ensure that that is still going
to run properly
and not be blocked by the developments
is it going to alleviate the flooding
that we always have at tivoli woods
and i mean enormous flooding you know
that as well as i do it goes right
across the road sometimes
um i also am concerned about
um this is more about in my opinion
uh bringing in the the strategic road
network rather than building houses
and where are these loss of 100 houses
supposed to then be
built um because obviously if it's
supposed to be designed for 550
and you're now getting 450 where those
extra houses gonna be built
no idea at all so that's an issue for me
in this whole plan
um and i am concerned
uh about the medical situation as well
as everybody else because
it was it was on the tv today very
highlighted
that than it is one of the greatest
places nobody wants to work
no idea why because i love that it
actually loves that it's a wonderful
place to work
um and they can't get gps but if you
can't get gps and you can't get dots in
the hospital how the hell are these
people going to be looked after
and with regards to uh james
rate's comment um about they only expect
200 movements a day from my 450 house of
development
i find a bit far-fetched i think most
people will
lose their house at least once a day if
they've been stuck indoors
or even to go to work so i find that a
bit strange and by the time this is
built
um we're going to be so close to 2031
that
everything will have changed anyway so i
think he's
the projections he's putting forward a
little bit of skewed
um but they're my main concern at the
moment and it's basically a car
dependent area i mean you're not going
to put buses in to pick these up and add
up
i can't see that happening so it's going
to be a car dependent site
again like the one he minced that's car
dependent
and i think that we have to look into
this situation because
everybody who is going to live there is
going to need a car
probably too and is there enough um
associated parking and road network for
two cars for two for
per household at least two cars per
house but they're my main movement
uh points to put forward so if you can
answer those and i'll be most grateful
thank you
thank you uh councillor i'll come to me
and first and i know
james would like to speak as well ian
um thank you chair um so just coming
back on
going through the points so one of the
things that the reserve matters
applications will do
is provide the detail of how these
properties themselves get built how they
actually
sit on a section off the land because
you know given what we've talked about
in terms of the
level change and the amount of
excavation you're potentially going to
have to need
for the road how that's going to fit in
in terms of land levels and it is going
to be key
for the reserve matters to look at that
and obviously in terms of structural
stability that is something that clearly
comes through the building rig side of
the system
with regards to making sure that again
whether or not
you know what foundations are required
and those sorts of things
um the main points obviously relate to
and that obviously links to this it
relates to flooding
um in terms of um the points about that
the
the model that they've used for surface
water drain specifically
is looking at the existing flows looking
at the fact that you know it's
acknowledged that there
is existing surface water flows um and
what it this is doing is again it's it's
making sure that
from adding the development onto this
site you are not increasing
those flows from this scheme
and the provision of the attenuation
basin that's being provided it's
836 cubic meters of attenuation basin
is one of the key elements of that at
the lowest point in the site where
everything drains into
um it's very important that cases is the
local lead flood authority have been
involved in this because what they've
asked for which is enshrined in
condition
20 um is oh sorry it's
it's condition sorry commission 13 um is
is about no development taking place on
any phase until
um a a specific drainage scheme has been
provided
showing all the principles of what's
been provided in the flood risk
assessment
and to ensure that there is an
additional runoff from this site onto
any site
outside the red line and
specifically condition 15 is for a
verification report
to be looked at to assess whether or not
all the service water drainage
uh all the systems were in place they
were working well before any dwellings
were occupied in any individual phase
so these are all issues that have been
looked at specifically by consultees and
would be enshrined in the planning
conditions
that are here in terms of the 100 house
deficit um this site itself
in our view cannot provide the 550
because what you would do is you would
end up building
on effectively a safeguarded
archaeological exclusion area and you
wouldn't be able to build on the areas
where there are surface water drainage
flows
coming through the site um in terms of
where these
where these hundred houses will be
needed to to be found
obviously there is a windfall allowance
within the local plan
provision in terms of what can be found
in the urban area
sites can come forward to obviously the
local don't come through the local plan
and they can be within the urban
confines
and obviously if that happens then
obviously that will contribute towards
the total of making up for the shortfall
on this site there is a specific comment
about this
in the report by the local the strategic
plan's manager
um that that basically takes this point
up
uh as as a point that you know has been
looked at again because of
of that shortfall and before i pass over
to james with regards to
the movements point um in terms of
medical situation
obviously we have um we have secured or
will secure through this application
a a provision of a financial
contribution which is what
the nhs and ccg have requested
i understand the specific concerns that
members have with regards to provision
of gps
but planning applications and this has
been alluded to by cancer organ planning
applications
um cannot physically get
gp more gps through you know development
and applications like this it's about
it is a a a obviously a complex and
connected matter
but fundamentally what a local planning
site like this has to do
is ensure that there are suitable
contribution or mitigation from the
development towards the development of
the facilities the physical
infrastructure
and in this instance that has been
provided in a in accordance with what
the nhscc have requested
so we have provided what they have
specifically requested
and so again whilst it is regrettable
more can't be done in this process to
provide for you know to provide
additional gps
it's not something that in itself would
would stand up as an opposition
to this planning application as a
material planning consideration
um so sorry james i'll bring you in
again if that's okay
yeah thanks thank you uh ian um thank
you chair uh yeah you're quite right um
counselor
i was probably wasn't um i wasn't being
detailed enough in what i said to you um
it's actually it's 260 movements but
i was i fell into the trap of talking in
transport consultants speak
um that's in the peak hour so that's
that's the
peak hour flow not the whole day um so
in terms of um your sort of question
mark about the amount of traffic that
the development will generate
that's that will be the worst peak hour
i think what we need to consider though
is the modelling that's been done for
the local plan does assume the absolute
worst case scenario
moving forward if you have i mean i used
to live near a school
um near garland school actually in fanet
and
i would never come out of my house and
make a vehicle trip in the school
peaks i know how bad it gets down
nielsen gregory's school
in the peaks through there um and what
will happen in reality is people will
sort of
train their trips as such so they will
time their trips
it's generally a sort of 20 to 25 minute
little peak hour where you get the the
the bulk of the the traffic congestion
from the
on street parking around the school and
what will happen in reality is people
will
avoid those times where they can um and
also
in terms of there's the forecast they're
based upon
uh um trip forecasts that are derived
nationally
uh and they were done post um sort of
pre-covered so
obviously moving forward there may well
be a reduction in trips
um as a result of the new way of working
that people have had since covered
kicked him
lots more people working from home now
lots more people
working flexibly so in terms of you know
that the
modeling outputs within the transport
assessment the local plan evidence space
is really going to be worst-case
scenario and the
the hope is that there will actually be
a lot less traffic on the
on the network than the the modeling
shows but we obviously we want to make
sure that we've done a robust job of
ensuring that all the necessary
infrastructure is in place
um and also in terms of like the
transport structure just to kick on from
there
it is quite important to consider the
fact that the transport strategy will
provide those sustainable links as well
so
somebody mentioned earlier about um the
the site not being particularly
sustainable well it's quite clear
a junior school quite relatively near a
secondary school
but the inner circuit provision and the
on-site provision within the site
will provide cycling and walking links
where there aren't any at the moment
so moving forward you really have got
that good opportunity to really kick in
with travel planning
um and that will that will also assist
in managing the traffic impact in the
future
uh thank you james for that um i do have
quite a few speakers so if you
have put your name in the chat line uh i
haven't forgotten you in a spencer
before
if i do miss you your shout out me uh
councillor scott
thank you chair um yeah um i will
obviously start by just saying thank you
for the detailed
reports uh going forward so i mean
obviously taken on board
what the the planning report has gone
forward and obviously
our speakers with regards to the
planning um
i do somewhat echo some of the uh
comments already being made by council
album and counselor heart
so i mean so to go over those again
they've already been addressed obviously
the uh
slight um dismay with the the affordable
housing allocations and obviously
healthcare provisions etc um i did
actually want to touch more on to the
the the flood planning and um if i could
be
so kind to ask if we're able to bring up
that flood plan map
um because yeah i'm very um i know the
area quite well and i know that a
particular area is very high risk of
flooding
um having sort of cycle past there many
a times when we have
had large amounts of water is a nice
little
splash to come down onto um i mean
i think ian's already answered some of
the question i wanted to actually put
forward which was obviously how the the
the flooding assessment
is put forward and obviously it's looked
on historically
with that and do correct me if i'm wrong
here with the
the intention of how it's going to be
planned on to an actual
housing development model um obviously
one of the the biggest and most natural
sort of uh elements of drainage
is our fields are you know natural
agricultural fields
um they tend to soak up a large volume
of water so
obviously bricks and mortar and tarmac
do tend to have a more significant
impact and obviously allow
more sort of a surface flooding um
i mean so that that's my concern i was
wondering if we are able to approach
that because um
i did want to question the the
estimate in percentage of the floss
flood risk in area a
because um looking at the phase one
development which is potentially 134
dwellings
um i do wonder that a large number of
those
will be affected and i know we are meant
to be obviously addressing the types of
development obviously with the the local
pan and the
large number of members who approve such
a plan
and basically you know i mean i'm
starting to think that
this type of development for phase one
will be boathouses with this
sort of flood so yeah i'm a bit
concerned with that particular area
the actual flood risk in general so yeah
just to
sort of outline my questions again is
what is the estimate percentage of the
flood risk in area a
and if we can just bring that map up
again um obviously effect in the phase
one
and my next question was moving on to
so the looking a bit more into this is
the
southern water highlighted this been an
issue
and what caught my eye was apparently
a feature which was the
drainage system to be actually within
the planning it's
quite a a large feature if you want to
call it a feature
and again you know i mean obviously i
don't know if it's quite desirable to
live next to a potential
you know on-site drainage system and
if we can have a bit more information
that or what type of development of that
draining system will be or
if i'm even right into saying if it is
going to be an on-site drainage system
i think it's something i read within the
report of southern water
and obviously again how that will affect
potential noise um light pollution
and again the the viability of that
particular plan and the impact of the
people who will be uh
no doubt living there so hopefully i'll
make myself a bit clear
again you know i'm a bit of a garbage so
thank you
i'm not saying a word counselor scott
but i will uh pass you
if ian can come back on that uh um
yes thank you i i would have to to dig
into the
flood risk assessment specifically with
regards to percentage
risk it's not quite quantified in that
in quite in that way
what's looked at normally when planning
out developments is
to plan for developments of of a
particular storm event
within a particular section of years so
for example planning for
a one in a hundred storm event which is
obviously a massive storm event
and for certain areas of the site
planning first a one in 30
year event which obviously comes around
every 30 years so again
it's you know a little bit less but
obviously still quite significant
um if if i may share i will just present
my screen
back to everyone to just show the the
particular
map and how that links into the
development if that's if that's okay
means um so so this
is the the drainage plan that's been
mentioned so so not the drainage plant
this is the surface water flooding
mapping
that's been done using the model by the
applicant
so you can see that the the dark areas
here are
the high risk areas from the flooding
that's occurring that would occur across
the site in terms of the existing
surface water flows
so what the aim of the the drainage
strategy that's been put forward
is effectively how you channel the
existing flows
ensure that all new development channels
into the existing flows but also then
attenuates
the speed of runoff to ensure that you
are able to hold the water on site
and effectively to infiltrate at a rate
that means you don't result in flooding
on sites around there or indeed to the
residential properties
so if i just i'm just gonna skim through
very quickly to get to
this plan here uh and annabelle talked a
bit about this
um one of the things that's going to
have to be submitted as i mentioned
um in response uh earlier to councillor
hart
is a surface water drainage scheme uh
for each individual phase but looking at
a site-wide basis and that will be based
on
the specific elements that are put
forward in
the flood risk assessment and so that is
to provide effectively
the route through the site uh that would
provide still that those flows could
still occur
because they'll see occurring the moment
through the green open space and that's
obviously dictated
how that is and i'll see these are on
extreme events in terms of flooding
and when they would occur as well as
making sure that the highway network is
provided to be resilient for storm
events
of one in 30 years um with then
the specific subs feature that's being
proposed
um which is actually providing this uh
attenuation basin
here um which obviously as i mentioned
earlier is
is to take 836 cubic cubic meters
um so it's it's very you know it's it's
an element that's looked at in a lot of
detail
specifically by the lead flood authority
kcc
um in terms of looking at what can you
actually plan for
can you get this number of houses on
there can you make sure that you don't
result in flooding on the site from
surface water that would cause issues
with these
these properties themselves and
obviously that is why
planning conditions are put on there for
this information to come in
and effectively there is always a
solution
to dealing with issues of flooding into
but it may obviously increase
in cost depending on how things are
going that's why this site has already
accommodated some of those costs within
the viability assessment work
but as well as that it's obviously
something that must be verified it must
be agreed
that actually what's been put on site
works
to ensure that it doesn't resolve
anything before anyone can occupy the
properties and that is actually
it's a relatively new condition that we
are now putting on applications when
they have
um surface water drainage issues like
this um and it isn't fully endorsed by
kcc
you've mentioned with regards to
southern water specifically about
about the issue of drainage obviously
southern water primarily with regards to
sewage and foul water and i must admit
i think it'd be worth just touching on
this because i know it's always a
concern
for developments of any sort of scale
really about you know how does the foul
water
capacity work for this sort of thing um
we have got a condition again it's a
grampian condition requiring details of
the site-wide drainage infrastructure to
be provided
southern water haven't objected but
obviously they've raised a number of
informatives that they've requested we
put on
any permission that's granted um
but it is actually obviously part of the
water infrastructure
act that allows for um
a developer a house builder to connect
to the network
but it's for southern water to to
dictate the connection cost
which is then to to deal with that cost
is to deal with the network resilience
and make sure there is sufficient
capacity there so it's actually dealt
with
outside the planning system for planning
sense
it's to ensure that it doesn't result in
potentially pollution
to the area um because inadequate
drainage
no doubt obviously can lead to pollution
and we are in an area that we need to
ensure there is only very controlled
infiltration
to uh to the ground because of of course
of where it is
with regards to the aquifer so we are we
do consider these issues have been
looked at
in sufficient detail for outline but
there will be
there will be more detail that will be
needed to be looked at including by
the professional expertise of the
consultees as the development would come
forward
thank you and i see accounts scott very
briefly council scott yeah i appreciate
it okay yeah i think you have answered
again ian so i think i have made a
mistake with just um
mixing the two up so am i to understand
that the the planning there
with that um the feature that is
essentially
um for less of a better word a ditch for
the um the excess water to go to i mean
i suppose it would be better than that
and obviously the the information where
i've read about southern water
and its own sewage system is not related
to that just for clarification
yeah so it the the the basin uh i'll
refer to as a basin rather than a ditch
but that
that i mean that is it's a relevant
point actually because how
how aesthetically it looks is something
that needs very
close attention when it comes to
planning and again this is why it's part
of the landscaping scheme and white will
need further submissions and indeed
that's what the reserve matters is for
being southern water primarily
interested in
sewage in terms of the drainage network
the underground network and obviously
the local lead flood authority cases
here looking at the surface water flow
specifically and that in this site is
what
is the particular concern with regards
to flooding
thank you thank you very much for that
always very interesting the tivoli brook
um the council of ghana
thank you thank you um yeah thank you to
um
the officers who've obviously spent a
lot of time
preparing this application for
presentation to us this evening
it's um appreciated um
i will just stop by saying i do
appreciate one of the things i
appreciate as well is that
because of the reduction in housing
numbers the um
that has led to an improved biodiversity
proposal in the application um
but i do have a number of
number of quite significant concerns
about this application
um they have been mentioned by a number
of other
members of the committee but i do want
to reiterate a couple of points that i'm
concerned about
um first year councillor gregory and
council of parents and others
raised um some significant concerns
about um sort of woefully inadequate
um contribution to the ccg 388
000 um that sort of goes on top of the
existing
health worker shortage in the in the
area around the planet
and i do think as well as needed to
recognize that in this application
there is some work i think we need to do
as an authority
to work with the ccg to make sure we put
provision in
to try and encourage more health workers
to come and work in the area
because we know there's going to be an
increase in in housing infante
and we need to be thinking about how we
can attract
health workers to come and work in this
area
i also have a concern share the concerns
raised by councillor boyd
and others around um the loss of green
spaces
and agricultural land
and of course there was also mentioned
in the presentation
uh loss of some of the existing trees
um in the area but i think my main
main concern on top of those relates to
the issues raised
also by council of parents and a number
of other residents
around the actual suitability of this
land itself
for um for housing to be built
um we saw on the flood
map earlier that you know that my i'm no
no expert and i will obviously listen to
experts
but it doesn't look like the land is
suitable
for any significant housing at all to be
built on it
and i think that sort of had then that
knock-on impact
on the amount of affordable housing
that's going to be provided on
in this development of of 10
and i know yes there's been an impact
assessment
and there's evidence been provided that
to justify that
that significant reduction in in
affordable housing
but i i really do
struggle like a number of other of us
took to accept that and i think that
um we've heard in previous meetings that
um
you know affordable housing really is
needed and is important
and if the if these um this application
can't provide that
then i think we really have to think
very seriously about
um about whether or not we can approve
this application
um and just before i would like to ask
one question please just for
confirmation about something really
um if this application
is approved similar to the one that was
approved last week
there will be can you just confirm that
there will be
opportune there is an opportunity to
bring
the next um the next
the reserve matters application back
before us
for this planning committee to consider
before
it's um fine it would be finally
approved
thank you thank you council ghana and i
think i know what the answer is there
but
would you like to comment on that uh
thank you
yes is the answer yeah any reserve
matters can be
be called in if members do consider and
this application is approved
um we have in the past um sort of
you know agreed that actually with
certain sites that we would
automatically
bring the reserve matters back to
planning committee
um which does happen in rare occasions
uh obviously in this instance i would
imagine given given the quite
quite reasonable amount of interest in
this site that we would look to bring
back
the reserve master's applications and
indeed that they would be called in but
yes they will they will they will likely
to be heard before this committee
thank you uh thank you ian um
councillor zesky thank you chair
um interesting um presentation and thank
you ian and your staff for that
uh excellent um actually
put forward um i like all the other
counselors that have spoken
uh are the same opinion in the sense
that affordable housing
is a big issue for us and we do need to
protect that as much as possible i do
understand what ian has said
uh and uh that it's been addressed with
the formulas
etc uh and i appreciate that uh
it's probably not the reason that we can
refuse it
um the medical issues yes i understand
again
uh i think really all the issues that i
have listed down here
um have been brought forward by other
councils and has been explained but
uh um it's a very tough decision on this
one thank you chair
i think councillor council paul moore
yes thank you chair um firstly thank you
to all the officers for their report
um it was very concise and very
informative
um i i agree with all my fellow
committee members
in what's been said and so i'm not going
to go over uh
old ground on that respect but i do have
one quick
if we if this is uh for approval
deferred approval um will that mean that
the officers will make the decision
or it will come back to committee um
because that's my concern
um and and at the moment i'm very much
in in favor as council auburn said i i
want to see housing
we know it's going to be housing but in
its present format outline planning
that doesn't sit comfortably with me
either because anything can change as we
know
uh once you've got outline planning um
so at the moment with everything going
on i
i can't see myself being in favor of
this but i i would like to know
that we will have a chance to have this
back at the committee because i think
the committee
needs to make decisions on this
application thank you chair
thanks thank you councilman um ian i
think you answered that a few minutes
ago but
yeah if if i may check so the committee
are making the decision
this evening on the application the the
deferral back to officers
is for approval uh all officers are
doing
is getting a legal agreement checking
the legal room in consultation with the
legal department to ensure it secures
all the heads of terms
that are outlined in the committee
report and then
doing the administrative task of simply
effectively printing out the decision
notice and issuing it to the
applicant so it isn't a case that we're
deferring it
to do anything other than what's in the
report um as mentioned
any further applications for reserve
matters would be um
you know you know has the potential to
come back and obviously there is clearly
a lot of interest in this
in this site i think i just wanted to
come back at one point with us
the affordable housing point um
from the evidence that's been taken into
account
the site won't come forward for housing
development as a pro
as you know has allocated the local plan
with the infrastructure that's required
as part of the local plan in the circuit
uh with more than what's been put
forward
and that means effectively that the
benefits of what has been provided even
though it is
acknowledged to be less than 30
affordable housing
is that you are getting the the 10
affordable housing the
36 affordable rent homes and the 9
shared ownership or affordable product
homes will come forward
if the site doesn't come forward those
new homes don't come forward and so the
benefits of the housing do need to be
taken into account by members
especially when we're in a circumstance
as we are which is the
um you know we are a presumption in
favor of sustainable development which
means that we are
subject to you know the the restrictions
under
the housing delivery test that allows
for applications
um you know when they're outside of our
plan urban confines
uh to be given a bit more weight than
they would if we could obviously
meet those targets so we are in a
situation where the allocated sites
take on that much more importance thank
you chair
uh thank you and council right thank you
chairman um
thank you thank you and to you and your
team um for a good
presentation but i'm i'm not going to
repeat everything everybody else has
said but
i still have concerns over this lack of
social housing and
we seem to be getting a pattern now
um i don't think i think 10 is
10 percent is far too low i i understand
the reasons why but
i feel like the developers are now
holding us to ransom on this
it seems to be forming a pattern
and there must be some way that we can
say that we can't go between
i mean you know 20 or or even 18 as we
did at tivoli
um but i do understand where you're
coming from
i'm going to say something which
possibly isn't relevant but
in some respects it is what i'm seeing
here
when you're talking about the drainage
and the water
and the flooding i've seen this
situation before and it has
never ever been rectified and that i'm
going to refer back to a place called
hackney wick
there is a place called old fold
hackney wick and well street
all three of them are connected and when
it rains and it rains hard
the whole area floods that's all mr
chairman thank you
uh thank you councillor wright can i ask
you where that is
hackney right um
i know we're talking to margate here but
i think i'll take your point uh
a counselor joel bayford thank you chair
i too share all the concerns of our
speakers tonight
um on this huge development
but we have um had the benefit tonight
of
very very clear presentations and i feel
very detailed answers to our many
questions
i personally feel that at this stage it
would be impossible
to give any more detail than has been
given
at outline stage um
there have been clear explanations why
the affordable housing is ten percent
uh obviously that's regrettable to me
too
but um livingston has made it very clear
that that
cannot be more on any other development
on this site
um there's been a clear
outline of the adopted transport
strategy
questions relating to gps
flood management have been clearly
answered
in my view we should support this
application
at outlying stage but when it comes back
for as it i'm sure it will for reserve
matters
look at these matters in every detail
which i'm sure will be
addressed um thank you to everybody who
has
given us the benefit of so much detail
tonight and
for the reason for my these reasons i
personally would like to support the
application at this stage
thank you uh thank you for that
councillor bayford
uh councillor curry thank you chair
i'm sure all members appreciate um all
the work that's gone into
um reaching this stage of the
application um
most of my concerns have been brought up
and discussed
i won't go over them again i i just feel
that um
regarding the uh affordable housing
i always feel where there's a will
there's always a way
thank you chair uh thank you councillor
curry
um counselor pat moore
thank you chairman uh it's just a couple
of questions
uh if we get 10 instead of 30 social
housing
it's a bit mean there are 28 two-bedroom
flats
and we've been allocated 24 of them
for social housing bit unfair
the development will not be for local
people because nobody will be able to
afford them
apart from 10 social housing
and if this contractor gets away with so
much
what's to stop others from doing it and
always paying for the road works
and all this money that is being paid by
the contractor instead of the social
housing
benefit is it for i don't think it's the
than it
because kcc are going to benefit from
this
with payments for schools and libraries
things like that
that we will be paying for twice
and if we have to agree
uh with this or defer it to officers
why have we had this meeting it doesn't
give us any choice
at all i won't be voting for it
because i think we're being taken for a
ride
but thank you officers for all the hard
work you've done on it
it's been very informative thank you
uh thank you councilman moore um
yes i will ian you wish to come back on
that
just briefly i think it's just important
say with regards to contributions
that are being secured on a financial
basis
they are contributions to be utilized by
kcc
but they're for projects in planet they
are
to provide community facilities
uh and clear and demonstrable social
benefits with regards to
in education facilities in san is so it
is it needs to mitigate the impact of
the additional houses
on fanat um just on the
point and again i i i'm i appreciate i'm
repeating myself so
i do apologize on this it is on every
single site
the affordable housing issue is looked
at in detail when there is not a
provision
for a policy for a policy compliance
scheme
in terms of the specific bits on this
site and the
the actual heads of terms it is about
there are two
review mechanisms that would go into any
legal agreement which allow us to
re-look at
issues to do with highway costs if the
mrn
bid comes in there is potentially about
3.6 million pounds that comes
immediately into that infrastructure pot
and affordable housing pot to be
utilized
for those purposes um it is you know
throughout the process as well a general
review
to ensure that whether or not we can
actually get some offsite contributions
towards affordable housing
uh for any changes to to values and
costs
um and it isn't the case that it sets an
example in my view
for other developers because every
developer has a significant amount of
scrutiny when they put in a viability
assessment
and we do not as shown last week we we
do not roll over
and in this instance there is though a
very specific evidence base
that means that we've put the position
before committing thank you chair
uh thank you and um counselor heart do
you wish to come back and then i'm going
to draw a line
thank you chair um we've all had a very
interesting and informative evening i
think um one thing i'd like to pick up
on
uh just slightly is that um councillor
gregory mentioned that we
put our climate emergency in force and
because this is a very clean site in
other words everything is starting from
scratch
can we ensure that they look at the the
building coming look at either ground
source heating
or solar panels on these properties to
make sure that
our children and our grandchildren
actually
see something that we are doing to make
a difference to their lives because
all we're doing is building houses which
will really be
unefficient in 10 years and we could we
could actually set an example now to
make sure that we are doing something
for our
grandchildren because if we don't do it
now it never happened
thank you uh thank you for that
council heart um
okay thank you for that uh council scott
uh
members um i said i would draw a line i
think
once again uh an excellent
debate tonight on um the subject which
we
we all knew um
people wanted to talk about and i will
say as chair
and the reports we've had from officers
has been excellent and reading the 166
pages which
members you know more likely have done
very very interesting and some very very
good points i mean i know
the area which i'm sure you know as i
touched on just now the tivoli brook and
i can see concerns there
but what we've got to remember and this
is me
saying it to your sales members is that
everything has
and is being looked into there's been
some very very valid points
made tonight and the concerns about
affordable housing
i understand it's not all about me it's
about yourselves
um and i'm sure the officers but i know
their officers do what they can
on all that side of things a councillor
heart
you have a very good point there about
you know
years to come um some of us might not be
here i won't be here but
again the very valid point so
um i'm going to put this two members
um obviously i have no right to ask
how to vote and i think you all know
that um but
um please consider what has been said to
us all tonight
um in that right and say i'm coming to
yourselves
with the officer officer's
recommendation
which is to defer and delegate
for approval and remember also the items
will come back to the planning committee
at different stages so
for those who are watching us on screen
which i'm sure there are still
members know how this works if you are
for the motion please say so
if you're against say against
if you're abstaining abstain
so i'll go through the members um
council common cook for councillor alban
against on principle of affordable
housing chairman thank you
thank you councillor auburn councillor
bayford for
announcement curry abstain
councillor dennis abstain
councillor ghana
against councillor hart
on principles i think so i've got to go
against
councillor pat moore again
councillor paul moore
against chair councillorski
yes sorry chair um i'll go for it thank
you
councillor scott yes sir in a light of
um
with the information proceeded today i
still in no good faith can uh
support this i'm against chair thank you
uh councillor right
against uh i am
for it um i believe that motion has been
lost it has
right i've got come over to ian
thank you chair um so members of
outlined
specific concerns um primarily with
regards to the
provision of affordable housing on the
scheme i think that's probably the
through line reason obviously we've
looked at a number of the other concerns
and talked about those in a
in a bit of detail um
what i would say in terms of the point
to do with affordable housing is that
obviously in from the evidence that's
been presented before us
if affordable housing is to increase as
i said that will decrease the
contributions
to other things now that is a decision
that members
can make they can look at that as an
option it is for members of the planning
committee to decide what are the
priorities
of the district when it comes to what's
secured as planning obligations
but there is obviously that that is what
would happen
now this site is an allocated housing
site it is
bringing forward significant
infrastructure and so
my recommendation given that you know we
are in a situation where affordable
housing is the through line
um is that what would occur is that the
application would be deferred back to
officers
uh what we would do is we would speak to
the applicant we would work out
alternative scenarios with regards to
the affordable housing provision whether
or not that's possible now we did this
before
with the samsung grade application and
we presented a few different options it
didn't increase the amount of affordable
housing
but it provided different options now we
can look at an increase
in the provision of affordable housing
to some extent but what that will do
is it will decrease the other
contributions that will be provided
and obviously that does have its own
natural knock-on
but i think given that that is the
specific through line that my
recommendation
to to members would be to defer back to
officers to look at
alternatives with regards to the
provision of planning obligations
specifically in relation to affordable
housing
thank you chair uh thank you for that
ian uh members
you've heard uh mr livingston's uh
recommendation i know that is from an
officer which
um i will accept um
i need a proposal for that so it does
come back for you
further discussion on what you've heard
um
could i have a proposal please i'll
propose that sheriff
councillor chesky thank you casper zesky
a second applies
i think in that chair uh thank
councillor beaver
once again i will have to go through
your names
um if you agree uh please say so
if you are again say so and if you're
abstaining
uh council common cook for
council robin four cancer bayford
four council curry four
council dennis four council ghana
four councillor heart forger
uh councillor pat moore
councilman paul moore four councillor
zesky
four thanks uh councillor scott
spencer uh councillor right
four and myself i'm four as
well members that has been carried
um and obviously we will hear
the outcome and whenever that will be
so thank you members again thank you
officers um
that concludes this meeting uh this
evening
uh one thing i would like to say um
before we close um
this i believe unless we're going to be
throwing another meeting in before the
council's agm
in may but i believe
obviously members know that committees
change and so forth and so on
um we you know i don't know where
i think you know what i'm getting that
things do move around today agms
but i would like to say um i mean this i
mean i know
most of you personally anyway um
for two years as chair of planning
i've thoroughly enjoyed it i know i've
been on planning for 18 years now i
think it is
um in the last year it's been
very interesting and how it's worked i'd
like to thank you
all because you've helped me and thank
you to the officers
and uh let's see what happens
next month uh but again thank you all of
you for your support i think we've had a
damn good planning committee and i've
said that to many people
thank you thank you